this month the army revealed its new
advertising campaign it wants to
encourage kids to join who may not even
realize they have potential or qualities
required negative stereotyping has led
some young people to believe certain
jobs are out of reach the army wants to
show that although you may have been
called lazy week or even soft they'll
see through that example one can't get
off that thing
[Music]
[Music]
there the kid gets told he's lazy
because he plays on his console for
fifteen hours the army recognizes that
if a kid can concentrate for fifteen
hours then he could probably keep
motivated for long periods of time when
staying sweet don't really matters for
instance in an ambush example to the kid
who can't keep from cracking the joke
even at the most inappropriate time is
the kid who will relieve the stress from
some of the most challenging tasks I
think the TV and radio ads hit the nail
right on the head
clearly illustrating the point so I've
made it more however the poster campaign
needed explaining to me I get it now but
if you have to explain an advert it's
not really doing its job the Army is a
fantastic career and I want to see the
youth of the day aspiring to join the nd
rim show there if you have to explain an
ad it's never going to work
I think you know how there was an ad
that it promotes the emotional support
given to troops and I think that would
totally fail to target the people that
are most likely to join and and it's a
campaign that will fail and that's not
me saying that that's a guy called
Colonel Richard Kemp in Afghanistan and
and I think we're in danger here we know
recruitment is down in the Army I know
we have 77 thousand troops when we
should have 82,000 but I think it's
crazy to try and scatter gun and just
have everyone because not everyone is
suitable and you can't have an army go
down the PC route that is that is
inclusive and representative of society
as a whole you can't because an army is
not made up of quotas you know an army
is made up of men who are prepared to
fight and who are prepared to kill and a
lot of these ads are or the emphasis on
the emotional rather than the physical
and it has to be on the physical I don't
know why you're laughing after it
because because to have a cruncher to
have a quota in an armed force so you
have to save you give a quote of so many
gays so many trans so many minorities
that's not what an
there's no clothes what the Army's
trying to do he's not trying to recruit
me and it will get a certain amount of
blokes you want to join the army
there'll be so many lads out there go
I'm joining the army on leave school
you're not gonna stop me what it's
trying to do is fill the commitment of
the numbers it needs forecasting isn't
that wire Dapitan I got everywhere but
took my wider audience who might fit
themselves I don't have what it takes to
be in the army and the army go well
actually you've got exactly whipped eggs
and I'll give you an example of one
example I've got you know where I live
in Hackney there is loads and loads of
usare and don't even know anybody in the
Army don't even consider the army
they've not been tapped into and I'm
sure who tapped into them a few of them
will come there George I said some Tom's
down the years and Percy I've never seen
her I actually like to think I'm quite
unshockable when it comes to Carol but I
Adam was really quite shocked by what
you've just said just first of all I
wasn't sure what I thought about these
ads but listening for this I now think I
really like them and I would say that
you too
no offense at all I'm not the target
audience right so if you go you not
understanding them doesn't necessarily
mean they're not working because the
target audience is our people that will
understand that message they might not
like it and the thing Dave said about it
is it's kind of stereotyping on people
by suggesting their own games the
opposite those young people have already
bestowed it and so I invited to why I
was invited to Whitehall where they were
they presented it to me perfectly yeah
and I'm highly concerned that the third
thing is they didn't invite a person
like myself to Whitehall for an insight
briefed on what was going on
I'll tell you what I have done with this
right because I thought I thought I
putting it in in a format that you could
understand all right
I've made some toasters myself was first
LIGO private Hirsch needs you and your
humanitarian corporal Malone
normalization need you and your passion
your passion we say this
I was so shocked by what you're saying
Carroll is that I thought it was
basically agreed that it is good for us
to have an army that is broadly
representative of the nation I thought
why it's horse of courses some people
design for kicking their doors something
it was designed for mended people
dishing out food all right that's the
way the army but there's two there's two
reasons that I profoundly disagree with
you Carol
one is that it is simply not true that
only people from one demographic make
good sausages it was so the idea that
trying to recruit broadly will somehow
lower the quality of the army didn't say
that a lot you've talked a lot my second
point is that if you have an army that
is defending the security interest of
the country it is obvious that it should
be drawn from a wide cross-section
population otherwise there's no
confidence from the army and also you're
missing out on talent of the people in
this country now I think the problem
with the Army is that it is not big it's
not attracted to a wide cross-section of
people if he wanted to join the army you
would be looking at the fact that people
are starting wars rely on charity yes
charity if they're injured or need to be
really wise to people off but the idea
that we should not encourage people who
attract people from minorities women are
these laying every single young person
in Britain and not every single young
scientist Society labels some people as
finds on TV how phones people would say
it says phones lobbies we need your
focus a fan job we could also be classed
as someone who's an addictive person I
just stopped bringing the head of army
recruit a major general porn answer and
see what they he has to say so the army
sees people differently and we're proud
to look beyond the stereotypes and spot
the potential in young people from
compassion to self belief we understand
the drive they have to succeed and
recognize the need for a bigger sense of
purpose in a job where they can do
something meaningful I love this ad
campaign one of the reasons I love it is
because it's turning as you've said
correctly
I believe Phil which great they had to
brief you on it and maybe that is an
issue but but you said correctly that it
turns negative stereotypes into
positives and all these young kids have
been hearing that it's wrong to be on
your phone it's wrong to play games it's
wrong to to be emotionally sensitive
actually sorry it kind of is a kid to be
on a game for fifteen hours a day you
know whether whether they should be on
for fifteen hours is a separate
conversation to saying if you have done
that in the past that focus could be
used instead in the army driving a tank
for fifteen hours where you're also
dodging obstacle and bother returning
and that helps to self esteem for young
kids to know that the skill they have
can be an incredibly positive thing
right there Chris used in a very my
point so that's how I think the app
campaign is great on the representation
point and the armed force is not this
you know this Phil we do need more
Muslims for example in the Armed Forces
right so I was incredibly depressed when
Isis when they were at their peak there
was this horrible stat going around
which is true that proportionately more
British Muslims went to fight for Isis
than they did join the British Armed
Forces and it's depressing to hear that
we do need more representing them well
that's another that's another
conversation entirely but it doesn't but
we do need more we do we need a more
representative Armed Forces and in the
ad that is encouraging young British
Muslims to join our armed forces instead
of going wayward in in wrong directions
I think should be encouraged top brass
are saying that these ads completely
miss the core pool of the people yarn
about the people don't want to join up
the boot doors down and all that sort of
stuff take names and flat-pack people
they're gonna be there anyway they're
gonna join the minute they get out still
we're not going to recruit them because
I mean it's the people we can't get to
do we do you get when you joined up once
been truly sold on why did you join up I
joined up because I wanted to be a
soldier
yeah and what does that mean to you what
did it meant everything to me I wanna be
so I want to apply for
what was it to you all I knew about the
army want to join them at the time was
I've been in the CSF for about five
minutes I looked at the army as a
positive thing I could do for to do good
for my country I been told it was a good
thing to do we were in awe yeah
absolutely
we're in Northern Ireland at a time I
don't know mate of Mines brother would
come back for Noren he's in a parachute
regiment okay and even killed over there
and I fought right I want to go over
there and I want to do at all somebody's
stuff out yourself okay that was and if
you look after after after the recent
wars that we've had a lot of young lads
would have said I want to join the army
I want to do this I want to do that okay
sound as you slow down at the moment so
what they're trying to do is reach out
writing to have a pile of the field
marshal here I'm calling it into this
debate that's what now there's been no
shortage of passionate speeches around
this table actually but also in the
House of Commons recently but it would
be hard to find someone more passionate
than Labour MP Jess Phillips who did not
hold back while speaking about plans to
allow MPs on parental leave to nominate
another MP to vote on their behalf
instead of having to come to Westminster
with their newborn baby it's safe to say
her opponents have been put on notice I
personally will make a misery of the
lives of anyone who comes in here and
objects based on their patriarchal
paternalistic draconian old-fashioned
sensibilities also I would like to say
that it won't just be me making their
lives a misery it will be me and my
feminist army you are also by the way
show this one
[Laughter]
you can join in the debate by searching
for the pledge from Facebook or Twitter
[Music]